So, to summarize, the approach where we have the conditional move instructions,
we need the compiler support to do an if conversion.
If the compiler doesn't do anything, the code will be just left with a branch.
So this is not a fully backwards-compatible approach in that if we
add the conditional move instructions to the ISA, we're only allowing
the compiler to take advantage of that. But old code will still not use these
conditional instructions. This approach will remove hard to predict branches. So
if we have a hard to predict branch, for example,
through profiling we determine that a particular branch is difficult to predict,
we can perform if conversion to get rid of it.
If conversion typically requires use of more registers than the original code.
Because we need to keep all the results from both of the paths, and
also, more instructions will be executed as a result of if conversion because
we're executing instructions from both paths, not just one. And also because we
need to add the conditional move instructions to select the actual results,
the ones we want to keep, from among the results that we have generated from
both paths. Some of these are necessary in order to do if conversion. For
example, the compiler support is okay, we need that.
It will remove the conditional branches that are hard to predict, so that,
we want to stay the way it is. But the need for more registers, for
example. Can we do something about that? More instructions are executed because
we execute both paths. This again is okay, that's how we do if conversion, but
do we really have to have additional instructions just to select the results.
To get rid of this and this problem, we can change our ISA so
that every instruction is now conditional. Every instruction computes its result
and then writes it or doesn't write it to the destination register, depending on
whether a condition is true or not. This approach is called full predication.
And it requires extensive support in the instruction set.